in other news tonight a new batch of
Twitter files this time surrounding the
Russia hoax and Democrats efforts to
outright lie over and over and over
again all while the FBI abused their
power to illegally spy on team Trump
with Hillary's bought and paid for dirty
dossier according to reporting for Matt
taibi while Democrats repeatedly pushed
a totally false narrative that Devin
Nunes his 2018 memo laying out
widespread spying abuses was being
pushed by Russian bots on Twitter even
Twitter officials they said they found
no evidence that Nunez report was being
promoted by Russian Bots nor was there
any significant Twitter activity
connected to Russia but specifically in
January of 2018 the congenital liar Adam
Schiff and Senator Dianne Feinstein they
lied repeatedly and claiming that the
release the memo hashtag was being
boosted by Russian trolls however that
was a complete lie that was false and
even Twitter is now saying saying so
according to these new documents and by
the way but it didn't stop the Democrats
from doubling down on their Russia gate
lies why to push the biggest hoax in
American political history and for the
record this show with its ensemble cast
got that story completely right while 99
of the media mob was dead wrong and
lying just like when I supported Donald
Trump very early oh I got the crap beat
out of me by people saying I'm not a
conservative okay here with reaction
former chairman of the house Intel
committee Devin Nunes along with America
First legal founder Stephen Miller
welcome both of you Devin let's start
with you this was your report you were
right the congenital liar lied that we
were right the whole time uh I wish we
knew at the time I wish we found out
earlier this went on for what nearly
three years
yeah looking it's still going on and I
think if you were to actually have Adam
Schiff on your show he probably wouldn't
show up Sean but he would continue to
say it because no one calls him out on
it I'll give him four hours I'll give
him three hours on radio and one on TV
yeah I don't think I don't think he'll
show up but look remember what happened
here in 2016 Donald Trump caught
Everybody by surprise by using social
media successfully to win the election
after that point Obama specifically went
to Zuckerberg they went to Twitter so
this was part of an ongoing process
through 17 and 18. they all knew the
Russia hoax was exactly that a hoax and
their goal was not to just control the
fake news but to control the delivery of
the fake news which poisoned the
American people and I bet if you did a
poll today
I bet you would still have half of
America maybe more they would think that
Trump and Republicans had something to
do with Russia and it's a shame that is
really a shame Stephen Miller you were
there the whole time you followed this
daily as we did uh we all knew it was a
lie there was no evidence uh that backed
up what they said but the congenital
liar the Democrats the media mob they
pushed that phony conspiracy theory and
rammed it down the throats of every
American that I think Devin is right
people would believe it
well these Twitter files are positively
explosive they document how after Devin
Nunez courageously stepped forward and
published this memo documenting illegal
spying on the president
documenting the Russia hoax after he
bravely stepped forward this memo people
like Adam Schiff and Dianne Feinstein
and Senator Blumenthal
concocted and pushed a phony story
suggesting that Russian Bots Russian
Bots were promoting this to try to taint
the memo to try to taint this
Congressman so what we see here is a
systematic pattern where the people who
point and say Russia collusion Russia
collusion they are the ones interfering
in our democracy they are the ones that
are spreading lies that Poison the Well
of the American Republic they are the
ones who must be held accountable and I
am so gratified to see for example that
Adam Schiff
lying liar that he is has been booted
from the intelligence committee you know
Devin as I as I look at this you go back
to 2016 the only people buying uh uh
bought and paid for uh Russian
misinformation that was Hillary the only
one that talked to a Russian uh that
said they had compromising materials on
on Trump naked pictures uh naked
pictures that would be the congenital
liar Adam Schiff if you look at where
the money went from the Communist
Chinese or number one geopolitical foe
that went to the Biden family the
Ukraine I'm withholding a billion
dollars until you fire a prosecutor
investigating my son who admits he has
no experience in oil the one doing a big
oil deal with China is Hunter the family
that's getting a five million dollar no
interest forgivable loan that's the
bidens the ones getting the money from
Russia Kazakhstan Ukraine China that's
all them Devin the very thing they
accuse Republicans of they're guilty of
yeah look that's exactly right here and
the question is now what's going to
happen I mean look president Trump and I
were very supportive of Elon Musk buying
this company and I think we've been
surprised that Elon has been willing to
put all of this out and I think the new
Republican Congress should actually
subpoena a request from Twitter this
information so that they can go through
it it's been great that Matt taibi and
others have gone through it and they're
putting out these reports but also this
is only the tip of the iceberg we're
only looking at Twitter and Twitter is a
small piece of the pie meta which is
Facebook and Instagram they're the big
boy on the Block here Sean they've been
Shadow Banning they've been doing nasty
things and they spent remember they
spent after Donald Trump uses Facebook
successfully to get elected in 2016 did
it the right way before they were Shadow
Banning then they turn around they start
to Shadow banish they put pressure on
these tech companies and then Zuckerberg
puts in over 400 million dollars and it
gets worse into the 2020 election they
have an FBI guy that writes a thesis in
college about how Trump colluded with
Russia he heads up a group of FBI agents
talking to Big tech companies every
single week warning them there might be
a misinformation campaign in the 2020
race and it might be about Hunter at
least according to the Integrity had at
Twitter this guy Mr Roth we got a role
Devin you've been Vindicated Steve
Miller so of you and so is this show
thank you thank you all hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else